the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
[Music]
welcome everybody to the last stretch of
this wonderful 2022 spring chess classic
we are now on round number eight i am
grand master alejandra ramirez here to
bring you all of the action with my good
colleague christian curilla alejandra
always a pleasure to be doing commentary
on these amazing games from this
beautiful studio here at the st louis
chess club we are on the final stretch
so what do we have alejandro not too
much left here in this tournament it has
been quite an exciting one it's just
shown the level of chess that we have
here around the country we've been able
to bring players from the collegiate
level from the junior level even from
the
teenage young teenagers participating in
this event and they've all shown an
incredible amount of firepower let's
take a look at where they stand after uh
eight seven rounds we have a clear
leader in the a group it's ray robson
with five points followed very very
closely by sam sevien and ilya nishnik
meanwhile hans neiman and aranja kobian
they let the foot off the gas a little
bit especially aram and found himself
still with a decent score there up with
four points tied for sixth position we
have jeffrey shong and darius virtue
both through their games yesterday three
and a half points out of seven in eighth
position we have alex lenderman with two
and a half points in ninth position
camille dragoon
barely uh allowed sam sevion his
opponent from yesterday's game to escape
with a draw he only stands at two points
and mihail on tip of who just simply
cannot find his form in this event one
and a half points out of seven and how
about the b group alejandro we have
still a clear leader as we got this
result totally wrong when we signed off
yesterday we thought that chris replica
was gonna go down in flames and he just
pulled the game out of the garbage can
and turned it around and actually ended
up winning that game against christopher
you and because of that sits very
comfortably or well perhaps not that
comfortable
with six points and the reason he's not
that comfortable is because of this
young man very very young i mean by you
mishra at only 13 years of age he is
trailing by only a full point and
they're actually playing each other
we'll obviously have that as a key
match-up of the day meanwhile sam janine
is in third place with four points el
sharmurio de abadi with three and a half
and christopher u also with three and a
half not fully satisfied with those
tournaments and tied for sixth position
we have jj limarandi armand mikhailian
and
actually jjlimorandi and armand
mikhailian with three points apiece and
tied for eighth position we have robert
hungaski who lost yesterday as well as
titus strema vichus in the last place we
have harshit raja who lost a very
painful rook and bishop versus rook end
game yesterday against some kanye yeah
those those are always tough you know
that you can hold them but practically
it's not so easy especially with the
time pressure you sit there for six
hours suffering and you don't get that
half point it really feels terrible but
we've seen that a lot here at the chess
club i think
my uh my most clear memory for rick
bishop versus uh rook was nazi paikidze
playing against atonsky he had the u.s
chess championship for the us women's
championship and she lost to move 49.
lost the move 49 out of that defense of
50 moves max payne in chess i don't
think it gets worse than that that is
max payne absolutely but let's take a
look at what we have for you in the
tournament's
it's a 210 210 player round robins
classical chess 90 minutes or 40 moves
you get an extra 30 seconds per move
from move one and of course once you
reach move 40 you get an extra 30
minutes also the players may not
mutually agree to a draw in less than 40
moves they can find their repetition
they can find that perpetual check but
they cannot mutually agree to a draw
this is going to ensure that we have a
very combative event on our hands and
how about the schedule alejandro it's
very easy we have two rounds left uh the
eighth one has already started we are
well underway and of course commentaries
start two and a half hours afterwards
which applies also for tomorrow but
check it out tomorrow it's at 11 a.m not
at 1 p.m the round starts therefore our
commentary will start at 1 30 p.m so
don't be late that a co that is done to
accommodate playoffs if necessary in
either the a or b group for first place
currently no playoffs would be needed
but let's check out if the leaders can
be caught i have to wake up very early
tomorrow alejandro don't forget you can
join us join the discussion on social
media at hashtag springtrustclassic on
twitter also this show is broadcast on
both youtube and twitch and on which you
can also donate tell us a little bit
more about that alejandro we take
donations sub
we have bits if we for every 75 dollars
that we get we'll be able to sponsor a
full semester of chess programming for a
child this is a great initiative here at
the st louis chess club remember that we
take players all the way from the
scholastic level to the very elite
passing through the spring and winter
chess classics so please help us out
with that the 75 differently goes a long
way and how about uh the pairings for
today's round alejandro let's take a
look at that what we have in store for
you camille dragoon is playing against
jeffrey shong ilya nishnik against araka
kobayan would definitely be
the game of the day if we didn't have a
more interesting one for you later um
down on those
rows has niman is playing against dario
spirits which is a very interesting game
alex landerman against misha on tip of
two players that really did not find
their full form fully in this tournament
but the game of the day without a doubt
that sam savion against ray robson four
and a half points for sam five points
for ray that is striking distance the
pressure is on sam to win with the white
pieces if he wants to take this
tournament this is a traditional matchup
here at the st louis chess club sam
savion and ray robson have been
qualifying for the u.s championship for
what feels forever i think ray said that
he's played something like 12 or 13 u.s
championships in a row
and since 2013 savion's been there so
despite uh how young
these two players are their veterans
here at the st louis chess club and
always provide really really fun chess
we'll actually be probably jumping to
this uh game as soon as we're done with
the b pairings because it is crucial to
the standings and the b pairings also
has an absolutely crucial game yes all
of the others are very interesting
because christopher you against sam
hanin hongovsky is playing hardship
mikhailian is playing alimorani moriyaba
is playing strama [ __ ] but our eyes
are going to be focused on this one
chris repco has a commanding six points
is playing the youngster the rising star
everybody is talking about him it's abby
manumisha with 13 years of age he can
currently catch chris repco by defeating
him with the black pieces that is of
course a very tall order especially as
slippery as chris has been throughout
the entire tournament christian we have
two crucial games going on upstairs take
us through one of them absolutely
alejandro actually i'm going to take you
through both of them because right now
both of those are exploding let's start
with the a group the battle between sam
sevilla and ray robson and comparing
these four players two situations both
in a group and the b group for the
leadership position well the players
with the white pieces the players
hunting the leaders are kind of in the
same situation they have to win this
game specifically sam savion is right
now playing with the white pieces he's
half a point behind behind ray robson
and tomorrow he's playing with the black
pieces it's very very difficult to win
with the black pieces abimanu of course
he's one point behind chris repko so he
really needs to win that game let's see
what is happening we're going to start
with the game between sam savion and ray
robson and we see sam opening up with
the english c4 e5 probably the best
response against c4 depending on your
style knight to c3 knight to f6 knight
to f3 and now we've seen quite a few
approaches in uh this tournament one of
the most interesting one was actually
this move e4 which sam savion uncorked
in round number one against ilya nishnik
instead of that ray robson plays the
move knight to c6 this is the typical
way uh to deal with this situation the
four knights english and now we see g3
d5
and the transition in what looks like a
reversed sicilian bishop to g2 bishop to
c5 castle castle d3 h6 knight xd5 queen
takes d5 bishop to d2 again there are a
lot of ways in which both players can
play uh at this juncture in the position
and we see a5 allowing any sort of
discovery attacks with this bishop on g2
but the thing is this knight doesn't
have where to go uh with a huge impact
you can go to g5 but that's just only
going to allow you to transfer the
knight more towards the center that's
definitely an option right i'm just
going to go back you can go to e4 and
now we have a very typical position but
instead of that
white decides to keep the tension on
this diagonal with this move bishop to
c3 which in fact creates the threat of
taking on e5 and that's going to be a
discovery attack against the queen you
have to rethree the queen right now
which he does he plays queen to e6
knight to d2 a4 knight c4 f6 and now we
have more of a maneuvering game both
parties are going to try to find the
ideal squares for their pieces we see
this knight coming from f3 all the way
to c4 on the other side but more
importantly opening up the action of the
fiance bishop on g2 very very important
piece for white rook to d8 queen to d2
queen to e7 opening the avenue for this
bishop so that black can finish its
development
queen to c2 rook to a6 bishop takes c6
b takes c6 of course if you take with
the rook uh i can take on a4 and
this is the trade-off right now so white
gave up probably the best piece that he
has in the position in return for that
he uh gathered one pawn that's a pretty
nice uh advantage nevertheless the
problem is that your light squares
around the king are becoming weaker and
weaker uh by with every move and black
is potentially going to be able to land
the bishop on h3 then uh try to transfer
the nut the queen on the long diagonal
with immediate uh threats of checkmate
on g2 so black definitely has a lot of
compensation for the lost pawn instead
of that
ray robson decided to take on c6 with
the pawn preserve
the control over this pawn on a4 this
rook is defending the pawn on a4 and now
we see this move knight to a5 a very
intriguing approach opening up the c
file and
at this juncture ray robson blundered
horrendously
with this move bishop to h3 which in
fact loses the game on the spot
because white has this simple retreat
bishop to d2 or bishop to e1 a very easy
move to miss this retreating move
backwards moves are very easy to miss he
played the move bishop to d2 actually
he played a move bishop to e1 which is
in fact the most precise move in the
position we were looking at uh this
position uh with with alejandro and um
we were considering bishop to d2 to be
the much more practical approach of
course you see both moves but it looks
like bishop d2 is a bit more active
nevertheless it seems like sam savion
understands this is even a better move
than bishop to d2 and right now black is
completely lost
your bishop on c5 is under threat but
more importantly i also have this threat
of queen to c4 a double attack so for
example if you try to retreat with the
bishop on d6 i'm going to go queen to c4
then i'm going to pick up the rook on a6
you're going to pick up my rook on f1
i'm going to pick up your bishop and i'm
going to be a piece up at the end of
this whole story so right now you
probably have to take on f1 but i can
just simply capture back on f1 how do
you defend the bishop on c5 well you can
do rook to d5 right it seems like this
one solves both problems you defend the
bishop on c5 but also queen to c4 is no
longer a double attack forget about that
i'm going to
distract this rook force it off the d5
square you have to go to d4 then i'm
just going to pick up the bishop which
is going to lead to a transition into a
completely winning end game for white
two pieces for the rook but uh much more
important is that i don't have any
weaknesses as white you're probably
going to get this pawn on d3 but that's
not going to mean much my pawn structure
is still intact i'm going to start
collecting your pawns i'm going to take
with the knight on c6 then re-3 then i'm
going to put more pressure on c7 this is
just completely losing
bishop to d2 bishop to e1 was played
rook to b6
and now i can just simply take
completely winning sam savion might be
taking the sole lead in this event with
a victory against ray robson and while
we were talking about this game it seems
like ilya nishnik has won his game
against uh aramha kobian alejandro maybe
you will show that but let's take a look
at what happened in the other key
matchup of the round the one between
chris rapko and abi manu mishra because
well this one is not going great for the
leader either let's see how we got there
d4 d5 c4
c6 we have the slav by the way abimanu
has been playing this particular
variation every single game in this
event with the black pieces everybody
opened up with the move d4 everybody
went into this particular variation and
if you remember alejandro well i'm sure
you remember because it was uh the game
of your student alimorandi in this
position he played this move a g3
which was my student's choice as well
what a coincidence yeah
i mean stealing is still in my notes
what is this
i told you not to tell me anything
c4 bishop to g2 now we have this
variation knight d7 castle
b5 the same thing that was played in
that particular game and alim around
this started with uh this move e4 which
is a very normal move natural move
you're trying to grab more space in the
center also you're going to play the
move e5 which is going to force the
knights to land on more or less an
awkward position and then your king side
is going to be a bit weakened we saw
what that led to in that game that was a
complete destruction by white instead of
that
chris wrap cup plays this move knight to
g5 immediately opening up this diagonal
attacking the pawn on c6 black has to
find a way to defend of course if you go
bishop to b7 i can just simply take on
b5 and this is going to be uh well
pretty problematic for black because
the pawns are equal if you uh try to
recapture on b5 then you're going to
lose the light square bishop and the
light square bishop is extremely
important this is going to allow my
light square bishop to become the
dominant force in the position so that's
not acceptable for uh for black queen to
b6 was played b3 take take and by the
way this is all some sort of uh obscure
theory bishop to f4 bishop to b7
a4
attacking the pawn on b5 a6 keeping the
tension there and now a big mistake by
uh chris redka and i will definitely
have a talk with him after the game
because
we looked at this position at home
we looked at this position at home maybe
like 20 minutes before the round started
and uh knight c4 was the move even i
remember
um and i i did not go through all of the
lines with him he was supposed to repeat
his lines i remember seeing this knight
c4 now the key idea behind it is
that right now if you go
uh h6 i can take on e6
which leads to a wild position that
favors white because you take i take now
i have a huge threat of
playing knight to d6 which is going to
lead to a completely winning uh
devastating attack for white you have to
take on e4 now i'm just simply going to
take back not going to be able uh to
castle as black your king is going to be
weak forever and i have a consistent
attack for the next 10 or 15 moves as
white this is not good news and the
engine agrees with this as well
instead of that he played the move
knight g4 now the difference is that
right now black can just simply castle
and by the way if you go knight c4 a new
castle the same problem arises in the
position knight takes e6 so what you
have to do instead of castle you have to
play h6 or take on e4
now
after knight g4 i don't have to take on
e4 i don't have to exchange one pair of
knights i'm just simply going to go
castle which happened in the game and
this actually right now is just a
slightly better position for black right
upon the pawn a pawn is a pawn and it's
very important that a pair of knights is
off the board so that the c file can be
opened up and i can uh continue my
pressure on this pawn on c6 right now
the position is kind of awkward for
white species and we got into this
situation knight to g4 a very powerful
move rook to f1 bishop takes f3 g takes
f3 knight to e5 now the king without the
assistance of the light square bishop
around it it becomes very very weak and
after knight xf3 king to g2 queen to b7
queen to e3 now black is just
breaking through this knight is going to
be lost which it was and this to be
honest it's just a completely losing
position
black will have to go to c8 defend uh
the entrance on b8 and this is going to
be all she wrote yeah this movement is
on the board an extra piece absolutely
no compensation
unfortunately for chris
for the leader in this event i don't see
this
um being salvageable no a piece is a
piece and
it has still a couple of practical
problems the pawn on a7 is very annoying
but it's so much extra material that you
imagine yeah it's too much uh let's take
a look at what's going on in games from
group a we do have a victor already as
ilya nishnik has defeated aramjo already
stems from this position it's kind of a
weird one as you can see that this king
actually is on f6 uh and it proves to be
a crucial part of the game now the
engines sai was looking at it while
you're explaining those games christian
say that after rook c8 white's a bit
better but not that much
but rook d2 apparently was a big mistake
and it was based on a miscalculation by
aram which is rare he actually is a
fantastic calculator and i'm not
entirely sure what it is that he missed
uh knight c3 is very obvious this is the
entire point of white you threaten this
knight e4 check it also defends the pawn
on f2 because of 94 check okay bishop c2
and bishop c2 check king c1 basically it
was really bad by the way bishop queen
c1 bishop rook takes and so far this is
not so difficult to calculate and bishop
e4 was played
bishop b4 is a very natural move because
you attack the bishop you cannot take on
e4 because check picks up the rook so
you have to defend this guy and only has
one square a4 now this would be already
awkward enough for me to not to consider
it but there is a killing blow already
the move bishop takes b7 again vacates
the
square on e4 so knight e4 check is a
huge issue but i'm also taking the rook
directly on a8 and you cannot actually
solve both problems if you play check on
c2 as was played in the game then after
the move king b1 this actually threatens
a full piece
because knight takes a4 rook takes c5
knight takes c5 saves the knight so much
geometry yeah so let me let me put it
let me put the geometry here i actually
don't know if it's the only winning move
i think even retreating the bishop is
winning but let's not get back down on
details this is good enough you have to
take on c5 because your rook on c2 is
hanging and at the end of the day then
the nylon c5 supports the bishop on b7
and black ends up down a piece so after
king b1 there's nothing better than rook
takes c3 but this is a full exchange and
at this level of chess
i mean it's a trivial win not to mention
that it's not like black's position is
very good and black flooded around for a
couple of more minutes but uh there's
just no saving this position actually
resigned after king e7 so a very
uncharacteristic miscalculation here by
aram hakobian from webster university
and basically gifting uh his opponent a
full point and an important one for the
standings lily has had a fantastic
tournament is looking at what's
happening in that sam semion game
against ray robson and seeing if he can
still fight for first place and i do
believe uh ilya is still
within the webster team in some capacity
yeah i'm not entirely sure i think his
assistant coach or he's uh in some
capacity still works for webster
university from where he graduated a
couple of years ago but these two
players know each other very well yes uh
so let's take a look actually at another
very important game of the round the one
between hans niemann and darius zvierch
absolutely we have a real lopez on the
board bishop to b5 a6 knight to f6
castle but very typical rudy lopez
bishop to e7 rook to e1 and
by the way just to mention um darius
wrote two very extensive books on rui
lopez covering absolutely everything so
his knowledge is top notch b5 bishop to
b3 castle
h3 bishop to d7 d3
d5 e65 knight takes d5 knight to d2 now
you can take on e5 the problem is that
after knight to d4
this position has been over analyzed
everybody knows exactly what to do and
in general it ends up in an equal
position yeah some sort of perpetual yes
yes there it's a very long line
perpetual typical marshall style
rui lopez instead of that white white
decides to go knight to d2 f6 c3 taking
control of the d4 square and also
preparing this move bishop to c2 now
what is this bishop uh doing on c2 i'm
going to support d4 and that is going to
open up my diagonal the b1 h7 diagonal
and i'm going to try to create some sort
of an attack on that diagonal let's see
how that played out knight to e4 queen
to d7 knight to h4 queen to h5 queen to
e8 queen to g4 we see this dance of the
queen on h5 going to g4 then landing all
the way to f3 knight to f4 take on f4 e
takes f4 and right now already it seems
like black is taking over why you might
ask because you can just simply take on
f4 well the problem is once you take on
f4 this knight on h4 and this knight on
h4 anyway is a huge problem for white's
position because it's on the side it's
on the rim you don't have this move
knight to f5 you would love to land a
knight on f5 that would be uh very
thematic and very good for your position
unfortunately you cannot do that and i
like what black did defending all the
light squares on the king side this
queen is nicely protecting this diagonal
because you can imagine let's just put a
couple of moves on the board let's
assume this queen is not here if you go
queen to d7 boom
knight to g6 that's a check made in one
move right so i really like what darius
did with this bishop on c8 this queen on
e8 controlling all the important light
squares
and now we see queen takes f4 he did go
for it he did uh give up a piece and
unfortunately for hans it doesn't seem
like this is enough compensation black
has full control over the light squares
now it has a dominant bishop with um an
opponent on d1 but quite a passive
opponent at least for the moment bishop
to f3 queen to f5 take take king to h1
knight to c4 the transition into an end
game can only benefit black because he
is the one with the actual material and
uh right now after bishop takes c4 well
it just seems by the way i'm not 100
sure if i like this move bishop takes e4
i mean i know i don't like it
there you go i don't know why i would
give take it over from here alejandro
explain to us why you don't like this
movie right let me let me let me get up
to this position and i have it up on the
board uh it comes down to conversion and
if i had to say what is dariosh's
weakness
in chess it would probably be conversion
uh he gets all these kind of positions
where he's clearly better almost winning
but
it feels like he makes his life very
hard and i don't really know what this
knight is threatening to do because if
you go to c5 i think i would rather chop
it off with the bishop on e7 and keep
this bishop on c8 alive so that i can
trade it for the bishop on e4 the
problem is that when you take on e4
and you take back i think with the rook
you have this double attack it's not a
huge deal because the spawn on h4 is not
the biggest uh you know factor in the
position but the main thing is this
bishop on f3 in many situations it
doesn't have a way to be stopped there's
there's nothing that's going to be
stopping this bishop and later on you
can imagine this bishop b7 take on a6
now is this enough for white obviously
not a piece is a piece this knight on c4
is monstrous uh you might actually get
an another pawn and you might have three
pawns for the piece but it still feels
on the verge of winning for the black
side
but
not in the verge already having won his
game today we have ilya nishnik who
defeated aram hakobian
ilya first of all big congratulations
you to know each other you both well you
graduated from webster i'm not sure what
your capacity at webster is right now
but you know your opponent aram hacobian
who is still a webster student how did
you approach this game
as as we can see by by the result of the
opening phase i i i failed greatly
i um i
i've mixed up all my home preparation
and actually got into uh into a slightly
uh dubious position out of the opening
but yeah i know that aram is uh it's
probably uh one of the very few people
who actually works a lot on the opening
phase of the game and uh and i i wasn't
i wasn't really hoping to to get
anything concrete any any advantage
shadows opening i just wanted to get a
playable position in which i miserably
failed to do so as we can see uh yeah at
this point
yeah at this point in the game i think
maybe i have slight pressure just
because of the difference in bishop so
my bishop is uh pretty active after my
next move knight d4 it gets out looks
like some sort of a catalan bishop but
with the king on the other side yeah
exactly he has a really really funny
looking catalan structure
but yeah it felt like i have a little
bit of something and and i think iran
probably didn't think it was enough
because he he he was a little bit
careless and i think this bishop a form
was what what gave me uh uh something um
something concrete and advantages they
can already uh be working wasn't yeah so
aram just kept kept you know approaching
uh really carelessly carelessly and
after roxy five he uh
uh yeah i'm not sure i'm not sure how
much better i am after roxy five but as
we could see from the game the one that
around around went for was losing by
force unfortunately and yeah there's
really not much not much to say there
uh but what he might have missed is
yeah if he goes wrong rookie two is
already uh uh yeah as as engine points
out there's a double question mark
because black cannot avoid losing
material so i suppose black had to uh go
into a defensive and try to defend the
b7 pawn right now which which would
probably
be still okay but once again black got
uh quite a few unnecessary weaknesses
for themselves with their last couple of
moves such as kf6 and e5 yeah i think we
were looking at the rook c8 oh
interesting that's the best way yeah
what happens if it just takes a pawn is
is the rook coming to c2 c2 it actually
goes check
oh don't really want to go this way i
thought i saw kc1 actually because then
rook c7 knight c3 and maybe i missed i
missed out on some ignition some draw oh
no no actually bishop d3
bishop g2 and knight a4 but this is not
this is not over is it uh we can also
bishop d3 can you go rook d1 there's
king d2 as well this actually this might
just be a draw no 95 this was this oh
yeah yeah uh this might be just a draw
of black takes on c3 though which is
kind of upsetting yeah so in the end
king d2 and i take c3 if bc just bishop
c4 this might not be enough to win i i i
su maybe even e4 maybe even e4 and i'm
wondering i wonder who's better
no okay now no way can block be better i
have bishop of one always so uh that's
true
yeah i think i'm still trying to win but
definitely uh yeah black can can build
some kind of fortress here but even
either way it seems that the
compensation is pretty very logical
right but obviously when so when when
you get in a completely equal position
out of the opening you're not looking to
give your opponent any uh any benefits
such as you know material advantage or
positional advantage so it is
understandable why aram was going was
trying to
to force things into into uh into a
forced draw and unfortunately blundered
i think what he blundered was so after
knight c3
bishop akc one rock takes f2 bishop e4
so over here if you go back one move
instead of bishop a4 i thought at first
i myself thought that knight a4
makes a draw which information doesn't
work because knight d5
so now yeah whichever yeah
this this very important check
wins me a piece because yeah my root
comes down and takes the bishop on c2
yeah
so that's that was a blunder and after
unfortunately there is nothing better
for black than
what aram do they believe which is to go
into this end game down in exchange but
that's that's just the complete losing
game it's not even just on the exchange
it's also positionally right yeah it is
a lot of open files i have i have poor
majority in the queen side how all my
pieces right there is just everything
just works out for me and
yeah it was really a really
heartbreaking way to lose for a run but
yeah
it really happens
you are the sole leader at least until
the other games are finished it does
look like sam savion might be converting
that game into a full point that's going
to uh have you guys as co-leaders going
into the final game who are you playing
the final i'm playing ray
we're gonna have like a very exciting
two final games because sam is going to
be playing jeffrey as black as well so
um
you're going to be playing ray as black
as well yeah so we both i i assume we
both will try to hold our ground and
let's see what happens
i i hold no pressure i'm already i'm
already way over performing
than what i've what i've kind of
expected myself
to uh to to do in this tournament so i
whatever happens i'm i'm happy and by
the way we did get the word that jeffrey
won his game oh okay nice so he's he's
one he's trending exactly so he's he's
one point behind but he still has has a
shot to to join us if he wins his last
game yeah that's nice well yeah uh a
very exciting round to come we wish you
good luck in that one thank you everyone
thank you alejandra i like the way that
this tournament is finishing up some of
the leaders facing each other in round
nine what else can we ask for from
around robin sometimes we get lucky and
we get those fun matchups where they are
playing for all the marbles let's take a
quick look at what's going on in the a
group which seems to be a very bloody
round today uh go around the horn very
quickly uh sam savion is currently up a
piece against ray robson let's just
really update quickly update what
happened in this game uh ray actually
played rook b6 gave up the full
uh bishop
on c5
and is hoping against hope for some
compensation here but
it is a piece
uh even though you will have two pawns
and maybe even connected past pawns if
you take on e1 they're only connected
technically
uh on c5 and d3 they're actually
completely isolated from each other and
as soon as you start blockading this guy
with bishop d2 and at some point going
f3 king f2 a piece is a piece and
there's really not that much activity
for the for the black side none of the
tactics really work out for you
i expect sam to convert this very
comfortably
meanwhile elia did win his game darius
seems to be in a winning position
against
hans neiman but still some work to be
done in that one especially because he's
very low on time alex london and misha
antipov are playing an endgame in which
white is clearly better but it is a rook
and game in which black has a lot of
activity off the top of my head i cannot
really claim if this is a draw or a win
for white because black is on the verge
of capturing the pawn on g2 and getting
some material back because of it
and finally we do have the result of the
game between dragoon and jeffrey shong
it was a very strange game in many ways
uh hopefully we get jeffrey in a little
bit later to analyze it but suffice to
say that the final position
let me get to it the final position
makes quite the impression on you as
white is not not even down material
actually is um could be up a pawn if he
takes on a5 but it's just collapsing on
every single direction the king on e1
should not be on e1 why is why are you
in the center why don't you have any
pawn defenses there's a pawn coming to
d3 forking everybody you cannot capture
on d4 e5 is hanging you're left
wondering why these pawns are on g4 and
h4 and why the queen side is also
collapsing uh with the move bishop takes
b4 so pretty much everything is going
here for black and uh it is not a
mystery
why camille decided to give up this
position so a rough tournament here for
the polish player
one of the
ball works of the ut rgb university of
texas rio grande valley
collegiate chess team for the past many
years definitely a strong opponent
does a lot of work in chess has had a
rough year dropping out of the 2600 club
and this tournament it it really has not
gone his way
let's look at group b
uh we have of course some important
matchups so let's go really quickly
through them as i don't want to leave
them abandoned uh this is christopher
you against somehow somehow is currently
in a clear third place
but
i think he's not anymore yeah he's gay i
think he's pretty dead here right this
is completely that he's i mean these are
three connected past pawns and if i just
take
take high five
push them baby pushing baby and it's not
going to last very long right you go
here you go there and you promote
somebody somebody will promote and the
counter play for black is non-existent
yeah this is over so christopher you
will reckon that victory
robert hungask is playing as roger
harshit
this one is not as clear as the previous
one but still you have to think that
black is winning in this one he has the
better rooks in many senses and he has
an extra pawn and it's hard for black
for white to coordinate with this rook
on g2 to creating a real pressure
armand mikhailyan is playing against jj
ali morandi you have to prefer white in
this position this rook on c7 is quite
nicely placed this bishop on b7 is a bit
passive and consistently needs defense
but
how much better is white
i don't really know you you have
problems with b2 is king on h4 is also
not leaving a great impression
i i don't really know
how much better if better
why it is the more i analyze the
position the more i'm wondering if what
i'm saying is true you do have some
threat with rook f5 i assume this is a
threat
uh although you still have rook f6 in so
many lines he actually played rook f6
immediately it was played which was
played just to get out of this ideas
uh and to finish very quickly answer
morgan diabati is has a bit of a mess on
the position against thailand vitrus
initially somehow i feel i like black
but i think we need to analyze that a
little deeper
and chris recka i guess that might you
mishra well one side has a horse the
other one's side does not have a horse
therefore the side with the horse will
win look if he survives this one
the guy has nine lives
maybe more than the more maybe more than
the cat but we are indeed with a very
happy victor of the round there is
jeffrey sean jeffrey first of all
welcome back to the studio you started
off blazing hot two victories after that
you cooled off with two losses with the
white pieces how would you assess your
tournament up to this point
yeah i mean it kind of seems like i
didn't ever uh fully recover from the uh
from the round three uh loss because
yeah at some point i was really uh
feeling quite good uh during that game
and all of a sudden he turned the tables
and i mean i ended up losing so
yeah it's been a really difficult event
for me but uh just hoping to finish on a
good note well definitely a good note
was today let's look at that game and
see how you finished your opponent off
yeah where was it felt like his position
got bad and bad and bad and bad but i
couldn't really figure out where it
started getting bad
it
uh well first of all i think this g4 i
mean i know it's an idea but it felt a
little bit
more risky for him because he can never
really castle long that's the main issue
because i'm going to hit him with b5 b4
and then in general when i put 9 on e6
it's hard for me to imagine
uh his attack really getting going
right and after g4 knight e6 f3 b5 it it
seemed like e4 actually made your life a
little bit easier allowing you to get to
that king on e1 uh yeah it's a fair
point but on the other hand i'm not sure
what else to suggest for him because he
can play you know something quiet like
bishop too sorry about that maybe king
of two no king after just loses yeah
king of two just loses i'm trying to get
the king to g2 but yeah i mean in
general his king's never gonna find
safety anywhere right so i think at this
point he should just try to follow his
plan
but after e4 i was actually expecting
him to take with the knight
right knight e4 i thought this was his
idea and i would go bishop seven and
then i
one critical line i think is if he takes
everything on f6 and tries to take on c6
because okay this gets kind of uh
concrete
i don't really want to play bishop
um so i was trying to calculate bishop
d7 i think
bishop t7 looks very tempting the idea
yeah queen f3 lancaster wasn't sure but
knight d4
defense both
but you got this very cool knight d4
let's put that on the board i wasn't
sure about it but
it's a funny position huh yeah because
i've got rook 88 as also
coming fast so maybe it's just good for
me
yeah
as well which way
short
thing is even this position right right
like if i want to at the very least but
it's this might just be totally lost
right i don't think you're stopping
queen h4
yeah yeah yeah it should be queen before
okay okay yeah yeah
should be yes
so so yeah maybe if this doesn't work
for him then um he has to try
instead of um okay
he can't take everything on f6 i guess
maybe bishop
okay i'm definitely better like if
bishop f2 i can you know play knight d5
or something right it's still yeah this
long-term issue with white's king i
think
yeah at the very least does not look
like a pretty um position for the white
side but better than taking with the
pawn i think
because it did seem that at this point
his position
it really starts to collapse i think he
did play resourcefully like he's he made
it tough for me to get in c5 initially
like if we uh continue on
yeah bishop four i think he has to go
and then yeah i believe what i did was
correct but maybe there are alternatives
also
yeah this yeah so now there are some
interesting lines um so my main point is
after d5
uh-huh
uh so i have two options
i think queen e5 bishop h7 gets messy
though so i'm not sure about this like
king had6
but uh i was planning b3 which i think
he
was afraid of this
and he has i think he has to go to b1
yeah you need to keep an eye on this
bishop right because of queen e5 you
need to be defending the the bishop and
you also need the diagonal tempo yeah
exactly so now uh
i think
i
my idea was knight d4 because queen
unified bishop g3 so yeah knight d4
and then
so okay the main point is let's say he
takes with the bishop on d4 plays d6
yeah i take he takes
and the funny thing is i might even just
play move like queen b8 because the
knight on a4 was trapped
at the very least so i i'm sure that i'm
getting back the material and then
his his rooks are disgusting it really
does not look like white surviving this
yeah right all right instead he played
rook c1
yeah i think ruxin was a good try
and then i yeah i like bishop c6
so now again b3 is threatened but i
thought here you had to try g5 whether
or not it worked or not just to go for
it
because
what he wants is if i go b3
queen b1 i'm not actually that happy to
to take this knight because he goes gh
and then i don't know maybe
now i think he's he's fighting somehow
so
it could be also a little bit of smoke
no
yeah maybe but
some d5 coming that knight has yeah if
okay
if i can go bishop c6 then then he and
it works then he's d6 d5 yeah i i was
assuming that maybe d5
yeah d5 and you have to do something
like knight e5
right right but maybe it does get a bit
messy i don't want to give up the bishop
though why am i giving up material what
if i just go back
it should be fine yeah that's the like i
want to see if white has some stuff yeah
i wanted yeah i wanted something with
rook g1 or i don't know
yeah rook g won but i can take this guy
right
start simplifying the position take six
yeah it should be yeah okay
it should be it should be winning but
maybe
it's messy right yeah
so he played b3 and it seemed like after
that there was just no way back for him
right right here after queen it's very
clear-cut yeah
yeah and then this position
it's just over uh well a nice bounce
back i'm sure that we were looking
forward to that win uh eluding you for a
few rounds you're a one point away or we
expect you to be one point away from the
leaders going into the last round going
all out
uh you're in fact playing with one of
the leaders
bro uh wait so uh sam's winning semester
completely winning yes and we can pull
up that game uh i assume this is winning
let me see what's going on uh white has
again one of those positions where white
has a horse
the opponent does not have a horse and
that's how we evaluate this one
that's a full piece that's a full piece
right yeah
i mean there will be some technical
issues to convert but
i'm not even sure you have any technical
issues to convert sure yeah yeah
this is straightforward
well jeffrey thank you for joining us
here at the studio we'll let you guys
tomorrow's an early round and i am sure
you are looking forward to it
yeah should be an exciting finish thanks
thank you jeffrey all right let's take a
look at what we have remaining here for
you we have a bloody round in group a as
we were mentioning sam sevien is on the
verge of defeating ray robson this
knight is just a bit too strong the rook
on c5 will start collecting pawns
i do not
think that this requires a lot of
position you could take on e2 to begin
with i actually don't see anything wrong
with it and after rook takes king e3
it might not be the most accurate but
it's kind of clear that c7 will fall and
that black white's position is just
going to win itself somehow you actually
don't give up a2 ever i think that if
you trade the eight pawns by some
miracle uh the game would not be so easy
to convert with the opposite color
bishops and that structure in the king
side but with the pawn on a4 it's very
simple you just pick it up and then you
run the a pawn later in the game but it
might not be the only way of doing
things he's probably calculating if he
can even save this h pawn maybe with a
move like g4
if you can make g4 work then should
probably go for it because after rook
takes king g3 black's pieces are very
much stuck
you would have to go back to h1 but the
bishop really doesn't have a lot of
squares
but you know i'm a lazy chess player i
wouldn't really do that i just take the
pawn and figure it out later it's a way
of playing chess and it's completely
valid when you're up peace
well one game that uh is up a piece is
that one the clash between the leader
chris repka and uh the chaser mishra
abhimanyu and we were looking at the
position a horse up yeah that's a
completely winning position but is it
yes and that is my question to you
alejandra i was looking at a couple of
variations here if you try to uh be
active with king to c4 yes this is
probably quite easy because i have this
check on e5 later on in the game so for
example if you try to go rook to c7 king
to d6 rook to g7 and say that you're
going to pick up the g5 pawn i can just
simply take take and now knight to e5
picks up one of the pawns and that's
just going to be all she wrote but
what if i go king to e3 and this is the
critical uh position and the critical
moment right now chris repka is thinking
is fathering his options if you try to
do the same thing then i'm still going
to go rook to c7 now
a very uh important uh key moment is
that you cannot take on a7 with the
knight because i'm going to go rook to
c5 that's going to force the king
probably to go to f6 or d6 doesn't
matter and i'm going to go rook to a5
and this is in fact a draw
this is a draw because you cannot move
the knight you cannot move the rook
without losing the knight and if you try
to spend time to bring the king on the
other side well in the meantime i'm just
simply going to be able to either pick
up one of the pawns or exchange both
pawns and that's just going to be a
technical draw so he has to find
something else he cannot take on the
knight i guess right yeah the rock c7
knight king d7 you can go king to d6 and
now we're going to get into this
position most likely rook takes g5 now i
understand
it's technically a win it's a win but
it's how difficult is it that's easy so
you're going to give a check i'm going
to drop back you're going to probably
attack my pawn i'm going to push it i go
check i go knight f5 i start all i need
to do is exchange one of the pawns
you're never doing that
that's the yeah that's the problem
there's a problem that's the problem
i'm actually going to pick up
the g pawn and transfer
transition into win a one king and
opponent game somehow so what if i go
here you give a check i go here yeah the
wind is not immediate right i probably
have to control your rook or something
it's going to take a walk it's going to
take a while it should be pretty easy
but it's not like i'm winning in two
moves or anything like that i probably
need to maneuver around yeah yeah
but yeah yeah the chris just saved two
opposition
incredible things incredible things
i wouldn't be surprised look i wouldn't
look it's completely
that is
that is the coach optimism
i understand so hard that is true that
is true that is true yeah i don't know a
knight is a knight i i don't believe the
chances that he has let's go through the
rest of group b
i'm actually curious on what on earth is
going on in this game between titus
tramavichus and al-sha maria diabati
this is the current
position on the board
i don't know what's going on so black
needs to take on this bishop but either
way he takes he's going to be dropping a
pawn right because pawn takes before i
can take on c5 i don't even have to take
on c5 right away i'm actually a little
bit more scared of what happens if this
pawn just runs and if you think with
this pawn then i think i don't know if i
trade the rooks immediately but after
knight a5 or trade the rooks i think
they're both okay you pick up a pawn on
a5 and
i feel this knight is just very bad
and the a pawn is actually more
dangerous than the past b-pawn
simply because my rook is already behind
it and this knight on d8 again is very
bad um
this
smells winning for
white it does and the only other option
is what about rook takes before right
yeah but then i take on a5 then brooke
is defended by the knight that's silipon
and that's still a pawn as i said there
will be so probably a lot of technical
conversion problems in this position
i mean white does have some problems
they say on the b file and stuff like
that the king is not fully safe but the
knight is very bad uh this king is also
not very good it's very far from the
action and the a pawn is extremely
strong yeah the thing that's the thing
right the airport is actually a huge
monster it's very difficult to defend it
we know or for those that don't know at
home
knights are really bad at holding past
rook pawns
either on the a file or on the h file
because knights on the rim are dim and
to blockade a h or a pawn you must
become dim so that's uh that's not what
knights want to do they'd rather be
blockading central pawns but this pawn
on e4 is just very far from it and you
can imagine for example if you take take
and i force you into into a situation
where this is a blockading knight and
this is a blockading knight well the
knight on c4 rocks the knight on a7 is
stupid and this for therefore this
should be a very easy conversion for the
white side not not to mention that he's
up a pawn and we do have a result while
you were showing up this position
alejandro christopher you did in fact
win uh his game against sam khan and
that was just complete destruction i was
looking through the game christopher
just simply didn't give his opponent any
choices and i'm sure we're going to have
him in the studio to uh present us that
game that's a funny little opening i
haven't seen knight three knight f6 d4
in
years so we can point it out there
absolutely years since i've seen this
opening
not very fashionable but it seems to
have caught his opponent
uh and he's going to take us through the
game i think uh yeah but this was very
one-sided even this position already
looks lost so we'll let christopher you
join us and explain that game uh
certainly an important one let's
meanwhile switch
to
uh the
jj game while we get christopher you set
up
and i think for the first time in a
while black black has a real threat in
this position
because this is a threat right
black might actually be better right now
that's kind of crazy considering the way
the game was going what a time situation
six minutes ago well you know your
student doesn't have any problems with
uh his time right not usually not not
usually but sometimes against the bad
positions but before we get into deep
analysis on this one we do have
christopher you with us he's won an
important game uh topsy-turvy event
there christopher tell us a little bit
about this game and some of the others
so far in the event
yeah i'm
pretty happy with how my game went
yesterday was rough
i
lost a winning position but
how do you very happy to bounce back how
did you bounce back psychologically from
uh that loss yesterday why did you tell
yourself let's say at night
yesterday
i wasn't really psychologically in the
right place but
i still managed to
focus and play good chess
excellent so let's see that good chess
on display in today's game where did you
feel you had a strong advantage already
in today's game
even after bishop e7 in the opening
that's very early
yeah the bishop b7 already i feel it's a
little bit passive like he should try to
bring his bishop to b4 or c5
actually that is a very strange move
yeah bishop b7 is strange
because when you play d6 and the bishop
is kind of boxed out by the pawn
a curious decision and it seems like you
took full bishop g4 encouraging f3
what cannot be yeah i thought you were
going to play f3 on purpose yeah i i was
confused by this decision too
that is then you said thank you
yeah
a6 green three
and it just feels like black is getting
no space at all
in this game f45 is coming
yeah yeah this was a disaster for the
opening
this is how i play bullet on chess.com
with white right yes with white of
course
yeah this fell apart very quickly for
uh for him and
no recovery right it was king's still
stuck in the center no coordination this
is going to be a threat one day
yeah yeah this is just terrible
and this helps you out a little bit but
hey this is just completely hopeless
yeah yeah okay big game for you uh
christopher who do you have tomorrow in
the final round abi mani mishra oh
that's a big battle battle of the
teenagers how are you going to approach
that game just like any other game
trying to play good chess
well we're definitely looking forward to
that one that big clash thank you very
much uh christopher and we'll see you
tomorrow thank you
certainly a little bit of rivalry there
be between the
youngsters he'll uh it's hard not to
compare them as they are the closest in
age in the tournament of course the
youngest one being 13 christopher just
turning 15. so very young grandmasters
that we have here in the spring classic
it'll be a pleasure to watch them grow
up to be mature chess players and they
are on their way thanks to some of these
tournaments all right what else we got
uh christine well actually i was looking
at the game of your student alejandro
and i was checking with the engine as
well he's completely winning that's
crazy he's completely weird he had such
an unpleasant position how did this
bishop get to b5 so i think you left it
somewhere around here after the move
rook to f6 i didn't like his position
he's lost that
for good reason alejandro because he's
lost
but he's lost after this
not so easy move in my opinion
knight to e2 so you want to bring this
knight to f4 now that blocks uh the
entrance of this rook also uh setting up
some very very nasty threats with knight
to h5 right you have to move this rook
away and that's going to allow the other
rook the rook on a5 to land on f5 with
devastating consequences this is going
to lead to a completely devastating
attack on the seventh rank for example
like this now
after knight to e2 you're kind of in
trouble
because if you try to go rook to f1 once
again knight f4 is the ideal square for
the knight because it it just controls
the file so well yeah wherever you keep
your rook either on
f6 or on f1 is going to control uh that
this knight on f4 this is going to allow
white to build up his attack this is all
she wrote plus five by the engine
completely devastating attack uh in the
end game and instead of that he went
the opposite way he played the move
knight way a4
now this is already a problem because
after bishop to c6 black at least has
equalized according to the engine from
an objective point of view but in my
opinion from a practical point of view
black is the one on the offensive right
now knight to c5 rook takes bishop to b5
first of all activating uh the bishop b3
rook to f2 g4 and now we have this rook
to f3 followed
by the idea of putting the bishop on f1
and setting up this mating net against
the king on h4
and we have the move knight takes e4 the
only saving race right now for white
would have been g5 to try to create some
space for the king unfortunately he did
not do that he played the move knight
takes c4 and right now if i'm just
simply playing the easy move
rook takes e3 it seems like
white's position is just simply
collapsing
the idea being that if you try to go
knight to d6 yeah that looks very
logical i'm going to go rook to f3
how do you continue your king is
extremely weak and it doesn't seem like
you have a good way to get it out from
uh this uh yeah the main problem is that
rp3 is coming right yeah yeah rugby 3 is
a very serious threat so if you take on
b5 i can take on b5 i think i can also
take on b3 right maybe there's some
knights b3 knight c3 forces the trade of
the rooks this might be equal but i'm
just simply going to keep both rooks on
the board take with the pawn on b5
all my pawns are protected all your
pawns are not protected you're going to
lose at least a couple of them this pawn
on b3 and the pawn on d4 this is uh
simply a very difficult end game for
white so what if you go knight d6 knight
g3 right or 96 is fine
okay yeah three knight d6 or f3 knight
f5 right knight to f5 now
the problem with knight f5 is that i'm
just simply going to play normal move
and how do you activate your rook yeah
it's kind of a funny thing because i was
trying to give you checkmate but this
bishop on
on b5 actually does a great job and let
me just point out that the move rook b5
probably fails so you see me take with
the pawn yes rook c6
f6 f6 yeah f6 rook c7 and i'm trying to
made you on the g7 square but the end
game after rook f5 pawn takes king takes
your king is all the way in the wrong
side yeah it's just completely off the
on the wrong direction and you're go
you're losing d4 with check and if
you're not losing d4 with check you're
losing b3
so that's two extra pawns and a
completely winning end game what a turn
around 96 on the limousine 96 is on the
board and we expect rook to f3 yeah this
is an easy one to play right because
rook f7 is coming there's not a lot of
ways to defend that i think so yes and
then
white makes some move and they make mu
40. yeah and that's an important detail
because alimorandi will have all the
time in the world to sit down and
realize that he is not playing for a
draw anymore that the tables have turned
and he sits in a very very good position
hopefully he can convert that one and
make it uh two in a row as he defeated
robert hingoski
yesterday
okay uh very bloody round all around so
many decisive results let's recap a
little bit the only two games that the
three games that i've actually finished
uh we have uh this one has not finished
but we can gaze upon hans demon against
darius spirits while i go through the
others
nishnik did defeat jacobian uh sorry
about this dragoon camille lost to
jeffrey shang christopher you as we
mentioned uh beat somehow and we have
this position on the board between
darius with the black pieces and hans
material technically speaking is equal
because three points are worth more or
less a piece and you can count them out
white has three extra pawns
but objectively i think the position is
just completely lost
for
the white side and the difference in
power
specifically this knight and this bishop
on d6 are doing a great great many more
things than the pawns will ever do the
pawns are not going to be attacking
anybody they're blockaded they're
actually weaknesses and the moment that
black can start collecting them the game
will be over for now i think black's
plan is pretty clear he wants to put the
king on f6 or maybe h6 but i think king
on
g6 makes more sense he actually went
this way which i'm a little curious
about i would have gone with g7 but at
the end of the day you defend the pawn
on f6 with one with your king
and you double on the g file
and you just say
uh i have more pieces than you do
therefore i can attack more targets than
you can
and it will be a winning engine of
course i cannot go to rook j because
bishop takes but i'll manage to do this
some way like rook here or here
i have all the time in the world to put
my rooks in the g-file if i felt like it
because white just has no threats uh
this structure is stuck this part is
stuck this pawn is stuck your only way
of opening up the position is going to
be with the move a4 but i have a feeling
even if you do get the move a4 in it
doesn't actually come with a threat i
can ignore a takes b5 for a very very
long time
and i cannot imagine darious not
converting this one uh especially
because he's currently on move 40 he's
actually made time control with 45
seconds left which is not what coach
wants to see but you know he made 10
that's enough that's enough enough it's
plenty
so
we're going to leave that one there uh
lenderman against the tipoff
uh i picked at the engine to check out
the evaluation of this it's surprisingly
even uh i would have thought the white
had a pull but the engine doesn't really
care about these pools things this is
just a draw
even the white is to move when you have
moves like e6 for example the engine is
completely unfazed by it says this game
should in in equality but uh i think
it's also clear that slenderman from a
practical point of view that is pressing
in disposition materials even but this
king on e8 is a little bit weak you
might be wondering why not the movie so
let's see e6 i take probably yeah you
take uh
and then you just run king of faith yeah
and it's uh
or you run immediately i'm sorry this
this is a probably the harder move to
find but you can actually run
immediately wait so if you take and take
king of fade it's just lost or yeah i'm
gonna point out the difference if you
take taking f8 and you go king of five
apparently this is a very strong threat
you're getting mated
but
so you have to keep the pawn on f7 to do
uh guard that g6 square you basically
guard the g6 square uh with the pawn and
you're able to play rook g3 as this is a
crucial
uh game just finished sam savion has
defeated ray robson and that is just
unbelievable for the standings we're
going to have sam obviously come down
and explain what happened there in that
game alejandro bad news
for yourself i don't like bad news bad
news unfortunately a lima randy after
knight to d6 did not find the move rook
to f3
very strangely to come b3
allowing rook takes f7 i think i think
he just didn't think he was better
that is one of the problems yes you are
on the defensive end the whole game and
then suddenly it changes yeah right you
understand that something changed but
you don't understand that you are now
in poor position to win the game you are
not winning so you cannot make that
mental adjustment and you only look for
the ways to make a draw and i think this
is exactly what he's doing he's just
trying to find ways to exchange pieces
and just simply make a draw
but
after rook takes f7 king to g6 i can
keep the rook on f4 and that should be
enough for equality i can even allow you
to get your bishop to f1 threaten the
checkmate for the moment but right now
i'm just simply going to give you checks
forever because you cannot go on the f
file that's just going to be a win for
white your bishop on f1 is hanging so uh
after rook takes
b3 we're expecting rook takes f7 it
doesn't really make sense to do anything
else in the position outside of maybe
knight takes b5
ignited knight xb5
yeah knight takes f7 but
not keeping contact with this bishop
doesn't feel right no i agree i it would
be a strange move for me to play i mean
i i think and he took rook takes up
several yeah sound looks very logical
and i think you go king g6 automatically
seven or okay
yeah this this is bound to end for a
draw i think yeah yeah um so that one
was the breaking news and also in this
game
we were looking at it from the beginning
of the end game and black just had if i
remember correctly a pawn up right
a4 rook takes a4 now black has a pawn up
a very powerful bishop
the more active pieces and it seems like
it's heading into a very easy win right
this rook on g1 is bounce defense of the
pawn on g4 this rook
probably you could put it on c7 defend
the seventh rank because that could
potentially be your only weakness as
black in the position and it seems like
the position is just simply dominant for
black
look where we are right now
um
things have changed well it's not a pawn
but that's not it is still up a pawn but
my pieces are so active and the
structure is actually not that mobile so
you have
five connected yeah i can count five
connected but these five connected are
and i think they're actually going for
uh for a repetition it seems like
they're
quickly just following up this line king
to d4 rook to g4 we might see uh we
might see a draw by the way king c5 and
they have finished they have actually
agreed to a draw
that's a huge miss yeah that's a bit of
a disappointment there for for raja huge
miss for harshit who uh once again
played a good game even yesterday he got
in trouble out of the opening but then
defended very well and then lost in
actually the final move before the final
move before he made his final move it
was still a draw
but due to time trouble situation and
unfortunately uh bad form he lost that
game i mean you get tired right i mean
this is hard this game is so long yeah
very disheartening not a good tournament
for roger it feels like he started badly
wasn't able to recover the few chances
that he's gotten he really hasn't taken
advantage of
and and certainly a tough tournament for
him he'll definitely try to bounce back
in later events uh let's take a look at
this game between elsha and moria
diabetes
and titus tramavichus
it has simplified into a position where
white is up upon but that is not even
the
the main worry of black it's the fact
that more of them are falling and the
extra pawn does a great job because upon
e3 covers against any chuck
so this king is super safe which allows
the rook to just go around and pick up
stuff specifically i'm going to pick up
the e6 pawn and currently black has a
pretty ugly choice you could go king g6
and lose this pawn
after which you have to defend it with
the rook but then the rook wins the
other pawn and you still could defend
with the move rook c5
but at this point your king's going
nowhere and your rook is almost one it
will be
it'll be time to find a win somewhere
around here uh i have the feeling that
the move rookie 7 maybe was not the most
accurate but
not really sure how to win this it feels
winning
especially with the king here well so
what do you play after rook 87 i was
going to just go rogue c5
and i'm i'm assuming that this is one
but i just haven't figured out how
so what if i just try to triangulate you
came to g3 yeah i could i mean i have to
pass right i think the only move is rook
d5
what else can i do right
ah but here i go rookie seven and you
cannot defend this point nicely yeah
you're you actually get zugzwang which
is pretty sad for black yeah yeah but i
mean there must be a way there must be
multiple ways of winning so you can go
let's look at that uh position after
king to g3 you can go rook to c3
yeah now i'm going to go king to f2 and
this is what i meant by uh triangulating
you king to f2 rook to c5 to defend the
pawn on a5 and now king to f3 yeah and
then you might have to start wasting
tempo with the h6 pawn but but then i'm
going to continue yeah i can actually do
the same thing forever and eventually
you will you will you will actually lose
and the key is that once you go king to
h6 you're too far away from the e6 pawn
and i go through six and the game is
over the game is absolutely over yeah so
we expect pretty easy conversion here
from al-sham they have reached moon 40.
you put the king on the last rank on
with king f8 or any move like that you
are totally lost so you really don't
want to be playing those kind of moves
but
not a lot of choices at the moment here
for titus i expect him to go down in
this one he's been very luckless in my
opinion in this tournament titus has he
has getting some good positions and you
know
through his own volition i'm not gonna
lie i mean some of this were really his
fault especially against uh hongoski
being careless there taking no time at
all and blundering a full piece titus
could have easily won one or two more
points i feel from this tournament
considering the positions he's gotten
and the strength that he has
but not on form a little unlucky here
and there and i feel that he's going to
go down in this game
so that leaves us with five remaining
games
uh antipov as we mentioned we think is
drawing against london and darius oh
they're going to think here for a while
i guess because uh he just made time
control uh i know hans played probably
extremely quickly here h2 he plays very
fast this game i think he still has
maybe even more than an hour with the
addition of the extra 30 30 minutes he
actually does he has a
no not quite an hour but he has a 37
minutes wow
still still to go
so the irish is going to sit down and
think how he can make progress
i mean i i i i refuse to believe that
this is some sort of fortress
i mean no it can't it cannot possibly be
right chess would be wrong if that were
the case
which is not wrong well somehow you're
going to get one of the rooks to g4
right
i don't know i mean i want to start with
the king going to f6 or even even
leaving it on g6 because you don't
really want you're not really afraid of
these tracks on on g3 right you go king
f6 and the moment your rook steps up to
g5 or something along those lines this
knight starts hopping around i go knight
d2 attack that rook i go knight e4 i
start taking on c3
of course you need to be careful it's
still a technical task ahead
but i have the feeling that it is it is
winning on the other hand you could
actually maybe transfer stuff this
bishop maybe should go to f6 not at this
position and you can also just start
with erika on g7 so that whenever you
give this check on g3 i can meet you on
the g file with my rook and maybe this
is just better better technique right
this is what we talk about leaving as
few counter chances possible to your
opponent and then transferring the king
then playing rook g4 then maybe
transferring the other one to g7 i don't
know i haven't really figured out how
you make the killing blow and i think
it's extremely important to point out
the fact that i also have the idea of
potentially opening up the position on
the queen side yeah with a move a5 i
have one extra break in the position as
black
while white doesn't really have that
option yeah i think a5 will come at some
point but even just putting pressure on
the pawns that are currently sitting in
dark squares and trying to force g3 i
think if black forces to move g3
it's a it's a nice strategical
concession
for the white side because the king on
h7 will feel a lot safer that no rook is
going to harass it through the g-file
the g-pawn is going to be quite weak for
the rest of the game as this is a dark
star square bishop and it's going to be
targetable when this knight lands on e4
so again
some work to be done perhaps a lot of
work to be done here by darius but
there's no question in my mind that this
is a winning uh end game for the black
pieces maybe you should even just
not even go for that just go bishop d7
put this knight on d6 and then go bishop
f6 notice the knight on d6 defense f5
and
just start attacking stuff right i think
that if you double on the c file you're
going to run out of pieces to defend
play the move
you play knight b2 which is absolutely
bizarre
but
it might be very concrete as well so
rook to g3 probably i guess you go rook
g3 i don't really know what else you
could do
and you could always go back here with
black but i assume you want to go here
is this really what he wants to do i
don't know why you would play knight b2
if you're not gonna go
although maybe here because it's rook g3
specifically as opposed to any other
rook move maybe here you go g7
or rook to c4
ah
because now uh you're threatening to
take on f4 and that's a problem if i
managed to take that pawn on f4 the game
is over yeah yeah this pawn is central
to white's defense the only way to
defend it is to go rook f3 and i really
don't want to do this no you can go
knight now i go knight a4 you don't have
the counter play on the king side and
you start taking on c3 the game is over
the game is absolutely over you don't
even have rook c1 because so
g3 is a bad move let's try to do better
i don't know if it's a bad move right i
mean where else do you go here look e3 i
guess yeah but the thing about rookie 3
is it comes with no threat at all so no
i can go knight a4 i'm just actually
hanging on
actually i'm going to go knight d1
it's kind of a funny move yeah
it's the funny move because if you take
on d1 the point is the bishop f4 check
actually picks up a whole rook even if
it picked up just the exchange it's
winning
but rook g3 have rook g7
and i think you do lose a four do you
actually lose yes
it takes e3 yeah it's a problem it's a
problem and then you take this
this work
yeah this looks
like you cannot go to
e3
but you don't really want to go to f1 to
f3 right because knight a4 is also an
issue
maybe an ib2 just kind of works
tactically that somehow the rook doesn't
have any good square so rook to f3 let's
kind of finish yeah rook f3 but knight
a4 now knight a4 and if you go rook to
c1 i can go rook to c4 by the way i
think a move has been played the thing
about roxy one is that you always run
into bishop b4 also bishop takes b yeah
also bishop i mean not not to say that
rick c4 is not winning i think it was
completely winning but rooksy bishop
before just finishes the game everything
seems to be hanging yeah everything just
hangs so it does go to rogue g3 i think
when you analyze it a little bit deeper
it is the only logical move in the
position and here the question is how do
you proceed because rook c4 actually
once you see rook c4 i think it's
difficult not to play it because it it
is a counter play preventer
the rook attacks the pawn and because
this loses the rook on g5
i mean you can give up the exchange but
who cares you'll be down on rook because
you take the square away from the rook
on g3
you you pretty much collect stuff right
you start collecting f4 you start
collecting c3 no it feels like rook c4
just finishes the game almost finishes
the game right yeah unless we're missing
something very obvious
maybe you just move the king somewhere
so that bishop f4 is not checked like in
h1 let's say okay i don't know if h4 h1
was a good square but i can just take
you have to go rgf3 i imagine this is
the only reason you play this and i
happily give up the f5 pawn because the
f5 pawn was the only source of counter
play that you had
like the whole thing was the department
of highest weak the best thing you can
do with the weakness is to give it away
and after king g7
all of white's issues remain
and i think black solved all his issues
you saw the problem with the f51
uh this bishop is now a monster you're
getting background checkmate all the
time maybe because of that king g1 was a
better move
but this will fall eventually this night
on b2 will return
and
white can't afford to trade pieces but
everything's on the f file you are bound
to trade pieces and this just looks
terrible for um
for hans i really don't think you can
save this but still darius is a few
moves away he has to find a few moves
accurately in order to convert this one
so rook g3 on the board we expect rook
c4 we also think that
there might be other winning moves it's
not we're not really saying that this is
the only idea to win this position
but it is certainly a very logical way
of trying to win this position probably
other same moves like king h6 and bishop
e7 are winning but at this point you're
trying you're trying to finish the guy
we've seen so many games in this
tournament specifically
where
players were about to finish their
opponent off
and they kind of
lost their way right they didn't finish
them off they didn't really
give them the killing blow the coup de
gras
and we ended up in
you know in kind of messes
where sometimes the game completely
turned around and you don't really want
that
for diary shoes actually been on the
victim side of that
specifically against camille dragoon in
a completely one
position on round one with a weird
material balance queen second two rooks
a lot of perpetual um that he never
should have
one player that was on the positive side
of that scenario alejandro is the leader
in the big group chris repka who is
defending or at least trying to defend a
losing end game but i don't think this
one is going to go very far because the
conversion and
i want to
give kudos to black to abhimanyu for
finding and and technically squeezing
the position as he is doing right now
because after rook to g8 this is just an
easy transition after knight to d4 i'm
attacking your pawn on f3 you cannot go
f4 you can never go f4 because once you
play f4 i'm going to uh sidestep you
with e4 that's going to create the past
pawn and that's just going to promote
king to d3
and now my threat is very simple you can
try to go g4 but now i'm just simply
going to take on f3 and this is going to
make the easy and quick transition into
a uh technically winning pawn end game
you can take i take i take and i'm just
simply the first one to queen my pawn
your one move short and after that it's
just game over e2 g6 e1
i'm gonna get that queen
you're going to get all the way to g7
just one more square and you would be in
an equal situation but after queen to e6
the game is over i'm going to go queen
to g8 that's going to be all she wrote
so it seems like abhimani knows that
white played the move rook to f3 king to
d3 and by the way his whole concept for
the last five moves is to get into this
situation
knight to d king to d5 or to g5 king to
c4
circling around like this and rook to e3
i really like this move and by the way
at this point
chris did have the option of playing
this move g4 and that would have given
him an extra tempo i'm not 100 sure why
he didn't take this extra tempo because
this is your only compensation and the
only source of counter play in the
position for white this g pawn this pass
pawn you have to push it as fast as
possible and try to create uh some sort
of problems for your opponent he did not
do that and now he's about to resign and
that's uh going to mean that abimanu
catches
chris repco at the top of the
leaderboard
wow that what a great result that would
be for the youngster
yeah but this is just totally over we
were expecting d3 signs right yeah yeah
king d3 and you cannot defend uh against
rook takes f3 wow what what a round
because the two leaders actually go down
both in the a and in the b group with uh
sam savion taking out ray robson and
actually setting us up
for a great round tomorrow actually i
i'm wondering i'm not guaranteeing that
we have uh graphics for tomorrow's
pairings but i would actually love to
see them if we do have them and let's
say they're working on it well we know
that christopher yu is going to play
with the black pieces against abi mario
yeah that's a big that's a big clash
might even be the game of the day to be
honest also chris revka will have the
black pieces i'm 100 sure against who
but he does have the black pieces well
who hasn't he played
maybe sram avicius
i believe it i believe it is i think
that sounds right i don't think they've
played against each other no so he's
going to have black against removichus
is going to have white
against christopher you who by the way
with a victory
catches up with abhimanyo is that true i
believe so
wow
i somehow i thought that christopher was
uh
he's one point behind abhimanyo and he
won wow wow
okay
so
that would be amazing for for what could
happen on group b it's still a lot to
play for tomorrow but also in group a
and in group a it's the same thing right
we have ray robson there who was at the
top loses to sam savion allows not just
sam to pass him
but also ilya nishnik by defeating
aramha kobian takes a tight pole
position so guys remember we have
playoffs tomorrow for first place if we
need to actually play we have a tie for
first place we actually will play that
over the board uh two rapid games and
then uh two blitz games i think if they
follow tradition from the previous uh
editions of the
of the classics and those are so
exciting i remember i i do believe it
was ray robson against jaroslav zerebel
if i'm not mistaken in one of the
playoffs it was there a book against
somebody admire he actually jar or jared
book
i think played
a played a final
playoff at a classic twice i think he
lost both i think he lost to robson and
i think he lost to meyer but i know that
he won with first move a3 he did
and i think it was in a must-win
situation yeah yeah and he won a game
with first move a3 well he does that
right he wasn't i think he was in a
must-win situation against cheer off and
play the move b3 and move one
and he won him twenty-one
uh yeah he's uh he's a funny guy like
that when it comes to opening
repertoires
uh so what else do we got
most games are about to finish actually
we might
fit no we're not gonna finish the round
before commentary today but but it came
close
absolutely one
one important game is this one of course
the one between alex lenderman and
michonne tipoff
and i'm trying to find ways for black to
mess it up
so
for example you cannot take on f7 i
think this might even be no it's not
losing
you're still within range yes you are
losing actually if you do this but
in fact after rook f7
this move comes on the board and this
actually would be quite funny king to e8
you have to take king f8 and apparently
this is just a draw really yes
because you're going to take this i'm
going to take this you're going to take
this king of six and i'm just going to
go king f6 yeah it's very annoying this
king f6 move because
um and what if you go here yeah i think
you're in time you're just you're you're
actually in time h4 this is one temple
it's a one-time opposition but you just
take on d5 and you're still you're still
somehow okay you don't want to go h5
because that's going to allow my king to
go back and catch the pawn
so you want to start with king to f5 but
then it's just a race yeah and somehow
the race is a draw which is kind of the
crazy part and it's a draw
that's hard to see oh it's very
difficult to see and this is precisely
why the players are calculating for so
long right now so rook to e3 was the
last move so you could go rook f7 you
could
and it's all fourths right rook f7 f3
you have to take you have to go king g6
that's clear you have to take here
no no no because d6 right losing yeah
yeah just instantaneously losing no no
you this is all force you have to take
on f7
and he must have calculated from afar
yeah before he played this move rook to
e3 it's also kind of clear that you have
to go e6
by the way at this point you don't have
any other moves as white because
you don't have a score still continue
defending this pawn you have to take
it does seem like you have to take on i
mean i don't see any gain from
triangulating or trying to be cute or
clever engine says king to g4 but it's
probably all i draw to it right
yeah it's probably all i draw to it yeah
yeah this is fascinating actually
quite an interesting end game i have to
say this is a cool end game rookie three
rook f7 recap 3 king g6 takes and what
if you start with the move
e6 then i have to take this one clear
yeah then king
d6 i guess
king c6
was there something wrong with king d6
no no
it's still a drop the x and king takes
e6
uh but then i take on h4 how is is this
because you are cut if you would have
your king on g7 this would be an easy
draw yeah the thing is that
uh
f and h are so many times just to draw
yeah that i'm wondering if you can just
go back with the king but your king is
not here i know i know but you're not
you're not going to push that pawn that
fast i go king d7 i go e5
i make some pretense that your pawn is
really not going to queen i go king e7
force you to an awkward square
and you
yeah you want to keep me cut right you
want to go rook five
but at this point you're running into
king e6 h5 rookie one i'm starting to
make some threats you're gonna have to
let me in
uh into the king side
you can't keep cutting me forever no no
i have to understand
and you can go king only seven or just
simply give a check
yeah yeah you're probably in time uh
black is probably going to hold this one
but let's not forget misha antipov is
really having a very difficult event
you're having the worst event one of the
worst events of your life
and then you're forced to defend
let me show you to you
this position out of the opening sorry
this position out of the opening
that's not a lot of fun i gotta say
well you're just simply a pawn now yeah
you're a pawn down and you have to
defend by the way at this point uh
lenderman had an hour and 28 minutes on
the clock so he definitely knew what
he's doing misha and hippo only had 53
minutes on the clock
so you're having the worst event and
you're under this tremendous pressure
and he kept his uh he kept his school
and it seems like he's going towards
potentially a drawing this one
well good for him actually sometimes you
feel for the players right and we do see
the move e6 f takes e6 d takes e6 on the
board after which we expect them with
king d6
but
uh king c6 as you mentioned christian
might also be
a draw
fascinating little end game here between
london and tipoff but the fact that he
was able to bring it back really from
the dead uh is quite surprising
uh let's take a
look at
oh this is a cool little situation here
between uh armand michalyan and jj ali
morandi because rook b1 was played
actually
knight takes b5 was played and you could
automatically take this uh
this knight but if you take the knight
you know start running into some checks
and this is clearly a draw but
i'd rather take white but actually rook
b1 might be an even more accurate move
you do give up a knight and a pawn with
check but the resulting position after
checking g7 because of this powerful
threat of rookie h1 checkmate
it might force you
it might force you
to give up everything back
with a check because i think the only
move you play you could keep giving
checks here on the a file forever it
doesn't really matter i'll go between g6
and g7 i'm not gonna budge
um and the only way to get out of this
checkmate is to actually play the move
g5
but after g5 i take which is a fork so
you have to take back and i take on b5
with chuck and this game this game is
dead dead the spawn on d4 actually
doesn't even survive a couple more moves
and
that's it king g4 yeah well i mean if
you play a rook on a4 yeah we can okay
four yeah but we can just sign the
scorches here kicking g6 and
the problem is you cannot get the king
to e4
yeah if you would be able to get the
king to e4 the game would still be going
on it would go on probably still a draw
but you will we'll be talking about a
game but with the king on g6 here and
the king on g4 yeah there's no way to
get the kids in there yeah i mean
immediately threading perpetuals
actually i'm threatening
kind of checkmates yeah
check me not really but like rook g5
okay g5 and you start trying but none of
this is going to
result in a checkmate so rugby won a
very nice precise move here by jj i
think this game is just bound to be a
draw
uh wrapped against manu it took him
quite a while but king d3 was played and
we expect
wait wait how did this happen
he went check actually it went through
the other way yeah
which is it doesn't change it doesn't
change anything yeah rook a8 played and
i assume that you take on
f3 or the rook or the knight or whatever
and then you expect your opponent to
resign
yeah
yeah no i mean i think rook takes f3 is
the easiest just because okay three king
e4 hide the king
and it does you you cannot exchange the
rooks on f3 yeah it doesn't really
matter at this point right if you want
to play this piece down well be my guest
but it's not going to be fun it's it's
not going to be very long either all
right uh nishnik won hans is in
trouble but i'm actually wondering how
what happened here he did go rook g7
actually i don't like that move as much
because of rook g5 and takes takes it
keeps hans in the game
and
dario scholling has nine minutes
and this game has finished as we
expected uh abhimanyu mishra
currently sitting in first place tied
with the opponent that he just
vanquished chris repko what an
interesting tournament we're gonna have
as a finish in group b and also in group
a but i'm particularly interested
if young abimendo 13 years old can
rack up a spring classic victory in the
final round but of course it's going to
be
with the black pieces
by the way against christopher you yes
uh no he is playing with the white
pieces oh white pieces i'm just playing
with the white pieces against
christopher you so he has a chance
look this was almost a must-win
situation for him
absolutely with the black pieces
absolutely and he delivered
the kid is on five and a half out of six
points in the last six rounds
that's pretty good he's going completely
berserk at this point and he's about to
win the tournament
well what were you doing at uh 13 years
of age alejandro i was were you winning
grandmaster invitational events i was
getting my international master title
and i thought that was pretty good
but apparently that's no good anymore
you have to be a gm and winning those
events yeah i think i was a fida master
at 13 years of age not even an
international master yet man
tough times
the kids are getting stronger and
stronger and
man there was a saying that you have to
take them young and beat them while you
still can but i mean the guy's 13
and i can't beat him anymore what am i
supposed to do now
very strong of your mind you know how
really has impressed the chess world uh
just at the age that he he made his
title of 12
it's unbelievable i mean there's no way
i could imagine being that strong at
such an early age by the way alejandro
i'm going to give you some bad news
the advantage is not
that extensive anymore it's not minus
3.5 as it was a couple of moves ago it's
only minus 1.7
yeah
it doesn't feel
that improving the structure for white
with h6 g5 was absolutely necessary
i was talking about this earlier that if
i had to say what is darish's main
weakness in chess conversion it's
conversion
for some reason he locks up starts
spending way too much time
and you can start seeing that with the
six minutes and 30 seconds left for him
as he's played the move knight a4 very
concrete
and
i i don't know you play rook f3 i assume
you have to defend this guy you kind of
have to defend the i don't that's the
thing i don't have to defend that you
don't have i can go g3 if i want that is
not a move i expect
i i'm not expecting him to play that
move but it's a move that he can make
and if you take rook c1 knight e4 and
now i'm invading i go rook c6
really and if i go h4
if you go h4 you're still close to
winning
but i will take on h4 you take on f4 i
go g2
yeah yeah i i get it yeah this is not so
clear actually these pawns are suddenly
gets a bit topsy-turvy yeah right i mean
i get a little bit worried here h5 is a
problem g6 might be a problem
this pawn is hanging and you don't want
to see a race with no it's on the clock
no no no no no no races so he's actually
played rook f3 and king g6 was played
maybe he was going to play kg6 anyway
i have to agree christian
not as easy that being said i have kind
of a clear plan here rookie 8 rookie 7
rook c7 right yeah rook somewhere
on the 8th rank that allows me
for example rookie 8 to transfer the
rook to c7 so let's see are you in time
to do that
in time i don't really know what white's
doing in the meantime
which has been the issue for the past i
don't know 20 moves right this bishop 26
is not really
threatening anything i'm going to tell
you all right
i'm just going to sit
and wait for you all right let's let's
go i don't know how do you want to go g3
all right go rookie eight i need to
defend that pawn on f4 king h3 or king
g2 or king whatever whatever all right
rook here
this is already equal
after bishop c8
what
this
what if i at least according to the
engine whatever c7 is completely equal
rook c7 and rook e3
ah
stupid engines
yeah yeah you pick up the bishop and
actually again the knight is offside on
a4 and i have some powerful pass pawns
especially this one yep
uh yeah this is actually a mess
so
so if you don't have this plan rookie
seven rook c7 which looks like the most
natural thing in the position
then what is your plan
yeah i don't know because this is not
this this knight is on a4 just to attack
a pawn right so it's not like you're
doing very much and i think the knight
g6 knight c4 yeah but i just came from
c4 right yeah but maybe you want to
transfer knight to e4 i don't know it
just looks like a beautiful position for
the knight this knight on a4 looks
really bad this knight was on e4 i think
all of these variations work
so i think i think step number one is
transferring this guy but it also feels
that the move uh sorry did i mean to do
that it also feels like the move knight
a4 in that case was a little bit of a
step in the wrong direction
he played the move g3 so right now seven
minutes and ticking
yeah this is not so easy yeah
why is he making his life so hard
and by the way it seems like uh moradia
buddy is about to finish straight
mavichus off take a look at that
position
yeah it just seems that well you simply
don't have any moves right now what
throne of interest is playing is some
sort of
a stalemate
he's trying to get some sort of a
stalemate in the position
can we
take a look at christian's board there
to see what's going on yep there we go
so
i think uh we are in at this position we
saw the king land on f7 we were thinking
about what will happen if the king will
stay on g6 and we saw that uh those uh
suzuang situations instead of that we
saw this rook two a6 h6 once again you
have
to stay connected to the defense of the
pawn on e6 if you go king to e7 whoops
that's going to be a check i'm going to
pick up the pawn on h7 and that's going
to be all she wrote so you he played the
move h6
king to g6 h4 rook to c8
rook takes a5 so you had to give me uh
that pawn
and now we have we have king to h5 rook
to a6 rook to e8
this is the only thing that i can think
of black is dreaming about some sort of
let's say king to g3
i know what you're trying to do
but i don't know what you're going to do
no you can take that but then you can
just simply take it
even not not that i'm saying rookie 6 is
not winning but it's it probably is a
win it probably is a win um
but it yeah there's no there's no i
don't see this i don't see the stalemate
it feels still made e because of the
king on h5 but you actually never
covered g6 as well yeah there's no
stonemate so you just pretty much just
pushed upon until the end you put it all
the way on a7
the rook
goes back to a6 to defend it this is
just that yeah absolutely completely
dead
so more idea but he is about to pick up
his a victory he's a very important
victory actually and what else do we
have we have
a couple more games we have lenderman
this end game is still going on yeah as
jj did finish that off with a draw
against arma mikhail when i expected
that for some time yeah what about this
end game
uh by the way we didn't actually not
actually and i do believe that black has
the option of taking on e6 and i think
he's calculating this line so take take
i take
king to e8 is the only move king to f5
it's a little scary i have to say it is
because you lose all your pawns you are
losing two pawns
but i guess you have king e6 and
this is losing yeah yeah this must be
losing but i think you have king e6 and
on f4 can get five yeah this is but the
critical line would be a um even though
this i think
you might be a bit scared of this no you
are yeah yeah like yeah why not right
hey why is this a draw
h4 so h4
f5 not h5 no no you have to
well if you go here i go here right yeah
that's clear
so then what do you do
you can't stay here but when i go to f4
and then i'm just taking a five handful
what if you go here then you go on the
other side
that's not not a super clear to me i i
think
i
i think i play king d6 here i it just
seems like such a natural 26 here
because i thought rookie six work date
is lost i mean that was my first
instinct but king d6 and i think we get
into that in game we were analyzing
already
with the rooks on yeah but then with the
rooks on i think okay i shouldn't have
any real issues yeah yeah
the bottom game really scares me
at the same time we know that michonne
tipov and we've seen it in previous uh
games as well he takes very concrete
decisions very awful so he likes to
calculate he's not afraid of calculating
uh precisely and if he does play rook to
e6 well that kind of forces rook to d8
right i mean do you want to play king 2
g5 probably not right rook to e3 you're
going to take this one
but this is the same position that we
had right now i have e5 and i'm going to
get the king to e7 we've seen this is
not difficult
so we are expecting rook takes e6 this
is probably going to end up in a draw
nevertheless
and deep off down to his last four
minutes
yeah it always gets scary right i really
don't like what he's doing he's just
taking forever
now his time management uh this
tournament specifically has not been
good no not so much
it it it feels like he got some
positions that he wanted to get uh i'll
prepare a few of his opponents but
when it when it came down to the time
pressure it didn't really look very good
for him and he's definitely let go of a
lot of half porn so hopefully he can
defend this one successfully but only
four minutes for him
all right let's let him think here in
this position
as he has a difficult choice to make
between king d6 and rook takes e6 but in
our studio we have a young man a young
grandmaster who is absolutely on fire
five and a half out of six in the last
rounds he is with christian kirila
celebrating his victory thank you
alejandro yes we are indeed with a very
happy uh victor and new co-leader of the
big group abimanu mishra abimani first
of all big congratulations five and a
half out of six in the last six rounds
how did you do that
yeah i just i mean after losing my my
second game round against ali miranda i
just
i just thought yeah like it's one game
nothing and i've i've been preparing for
this tournament for like over two months
and all that preparation like okay one
game can go bad in the tournament but i
felt that it will it will eventually
show you are playing uh this round
against the leader of the event uh the
invincible man in this event you are
also playing with the black pieces
how did you approach this game did you
see it as a must-win situation
yeah i kind of saw it as a mushroom
situation if i was competing for first
as such but the thing is like when
you're black you cannot
against a very strong opponent if they
want to make a draw of the opening you
cannot you cannot like just you can't
avoid them you can't stop them you if
you do that you'll just lose the game
right there so i just i just was i was
thinking i'll just play whatever lines i
usually play and just play a game if he
plays on and we get a game good yeah and
he did and he did play on and you guys
got a game and actually let's take a
look at that game yeah tell us a little
bit of the critical moments where did
you feel you started
really getting that advantage
obviously you're up a pawn but the
position remains very complex here yeah
i
actually when i was discussing when i
was discussing it with him a few minutes
upstairs ago uh so he said that this was
all his preparation and he's have
tonight g4 engine said to play knight
take c4 for whatever reason no no it was
not knight g4 it was knight c e4
so he forgot his preparation
and castle you have knight to c6 right
yes
yeah that's a big difference so now
you're forced to exchange one pair of
knights and that's a big difference
ah because i can put some more pressure
with the rook coming to c1 rook fc one
yeah that was the main reason why i
didn't take e4 because i felt it if i
took on e4 then he has like rc1 with
like one
one his uh it's a queen side attack is
one move faster
yeah
so
he castle then it felt like you started
to take over
maybe around here maybe like yeah c5
this is uh this is still a complete draw
after bishop c5 rook c5 and yeah he
missed the r5 move
and i think bishop f3 is a mistake here
actually why didn't he go e3
yeah e3 i think there's some some crazy
plans like rook takes f2 but i'm not
i'm not entirely sure if they work like
this should be seven
queen takes c queen takes e3 bishop
takes a8
oh my goodness and now like rook did
it's rook d it's a threat and if you go
like age six ninety four and you not
yeah ninety he could he can just give up
his queen
at least right
and if you
have no you have nothing with this rock
huh
the king is just very safe on h1 so now
you just play h6 even this doesn't work
huh
yeah i don't maybe yeah an ig-14 h3
yeah it just doesn't work the king's
fine on
on g2 yeah that's a funny line
rick takes f2 i guess he got scared yeah
but after e3 i mean there were some
i think maybe uh black is fine here but
there's like some lines which you should
avoid like bishop takes g2 is like the
most natural move if rook case have two
doesn't work but i think here white has
rook takes a six yeah that's a nice move
and now there's like two lines rook
takes a6 b16 queen c6
you can see how queen b3 rook dna is
made and now there's like rook d8
98 queen b8
and i think it was king of fade a7
and yeah if you go rook five queen
before you lose what about bishop f3
which have three bishop f3 ah you have
queen to b4 okay bishop f3 promote yeah
oh you promote and that's a checkmate
checkmate
yeah yeah
yeah that's the lost actually i don't
see a defense and instead of uh if you
don't play this if you go back a few
moves there was some issue with if you
play
queen b7 instead of rook takes a6
there was rook to say it queen they say
it queened a4 just make sure you don't
play queen a3 because queen takes a3
queen f8
but yeah after queen a4 you lose your
fees back there's nothing you can do
right because the threat is to trade and
go broke the aid and yeah there's
actually nothing you can do about it
it's kind of sad
yeah so i was planning to play something
else but
it's
weight should be fine i guess
but a big mistake with bishop f3 and you
took full advantage of it immediately
yeah
or in 95 yeah 95 and
instead of 95 i think rook takes f3 was
another move but
this also leads to some crazy variations
like rook takes up three knight d5 i
think
knight e5 knight d5 uh queen takes f2
check rook takes f2 rook takes b3
and now it has knight c7
and maybe black is somehow winning here
but i couldn't see it like rook city has
basics and i have two a7 so you have to
go to k7 okay seven you have rook d2
and bsx
then he just stays like that yeah
yeah i mean it's harder harder to say
that you're going to win with this
opponent on
a6 always being a problem yeah
well a lot of calculation in this game
was necessary it takes 95 94. and i had
this nice nayf3 queen b7 idea but maybe
queen bc like for some reason engine
doesn't like queen b7 i don't worry
about it at this point it says and
pretty much everything's winning yeah
it's already a complete yeah knight d4
is also like completely winning you just
take b5 it just didn't want to be as
fancy as you were but queen b7 is there
definitely a good move don't worry about
it yeah i just wanted to like finish
this as quickly as possible as such
because queen like 94 1935 will be
winning in the long run but again such a
resourceful opponent i didn't want to
take such risks and if you lose the a6
pawn then it's going to be a very
difficult conversion right yes yeah
well certainly a bunch of games one
there in a row for you just got stopped
with a draw uh uh one year ago yesterday
did you expect uh to come in and wipe
out so many opponents in a row
i didn't actually expect this but i was
i was just trying and as as i said
before i was i've been preparing for
this tournament for a very long time and
i felt very confident in my preparation
and now everything is working out
perfectly well you seem like a happy man
and certainly we are happy to see you
make progress of course all eyes on abby
manu the youngest grandmaster in the
history of the game and one final
question for you abby money tomorrow you
have a big clash against christopher eu
a player that probably is going to be
one of your main rivals for years to
come how will you approach that game
i'll approach it the same way i approach
every game just play just try and just
play whatever i can do best
whatever and whatever goes on after that
is that's not in my control absolutely
that's a very healthy attitude to have
good luck tomorrow and we're looking
forward to see you tomorrow thank you
yeah bright and early we have the round
at 11am and remember this is uh this is
gonna be a matchup that i think we're
gonna be seeing tons of times as uh
these young players will face off each
other at the very least in the u.s
junior chess championship coming back to
st louis in july
joining the u.s seniors and u.s junior
girls which are
awesome to watch they're very
topsy-turvy games but they always
provide very very interesting and fun
fun games and certainly those two
players will be participating let's take
a look at what has happened in today's
round actually in group a we only have
two games left lenderman is still
pushing against misha antipov but
we we got it wrong yesterday but i'm
going to go ahead and guarantee a draw
on this one although i hope that misha
doesn't make me look bad
and meanwhile hans d man is still
fighting for survival against daryu
spirits because i am completely biased
in my commentary i will say that he will
not make it and darius will uh score an
important point there
meanwhile in group b we actually have
all of the results already done
christopher yu has defeated somehow
maria de body did so against titus
taravichos in the game of the day
absolutely everything will play for abi
as we call them has defeated chris repka
and sits in first place meanwhile rob
robert hungaski will play against
harshid raja and surprisingly we have
pairings for tomorrow can you believe
the magic of television that we have
here in the last round in group a great
games absolutely great games jeffrey
sean will be playing against sam savion
miha antipov will playing as camilla
dragoon dario schwartz will playing
against alex slenderman adam hakobian
against ilya nishnik but ray robson
against hans demon i i don't even know
where to put my attention here right
jeffrey schunk some seven huge game ray
robson hunts neiman's huge game also i
think there's a mistake there aram
hakobian i think just played against
ilya nishnik today ah so an ilia nishnik
is actually going to play with the black
pieces but against jeffrey shong why do
they lie to us like this i'm not her no
no against ray robson yeah nation is
playing robson right now he's playing
ray ross we actually just had him in the
studio saying that and jeffrey strong is
playing sam savion so that one is
correct
it means that aram hakovian is going to
be playing hans nemo right i think they
have the power of deduction
because everything looks right i don't
think darius played lender man and tipo
is not playing against dragoon but
yeah i don't think nishan explained
robson right do i remember the romney
they tell us that he's going to play ray
robson tomorrow yeah but we believe him
let me i'm going to i'm going to i'm
going to check the brother we believe
him because we know that today he played
around her cobia so there is definitely
something wrong in
our parents and what about the b group
alejandro so yeah do we have the b group
all right let's take a look at the b
group we might you measure against
christopher you we do know that one is
true uh titus drama [ __ ] has been
playing against chris rupka ali marandi
will be finishing against moriya dibati
harshid rajyan not a very lucky
tournament for him will be finishing his
arami hylian and sam hanin uh against
robert hungaski of course all eyes will
be on the games of the leaders you have
them there at the top can chris replica
hold against titus dramavicious and what
will abi do against christopher you big
questions that are only going to be
answered here in the studio tomorrow
don't forget tomorrow we are starting uh
the final round a bit earlier the games
are going to be starting at 11 a.m
central time and our abbreviated show is
going to start two and a half hours
later at 1 30 p.m also we might see some
playoffs so
join us tomorrow also join our
discussion on social media at hashtag
springchess classic we will answer all
of your questions
until tomorrow i am grand master
christian kirilla with my good friend
grandmaster alejandro ramirez and we
will see you tomorrow can't wait don't
miss it the final and conclusion of the
spring chess classic 2022
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited
you